a good scientist is always asking  questions what is dark matter where does  it come from how did the universe get  here could there be other life forms in  the universe on my channel we take deep  dives into the most exciting stories in  astronomy cosmology physics chemistry  engineering and more i'm an experimental  astrophysicist so i'll also take you on  exclusive tours of the coolest new  experiments and simulations based on the  cutting edge discoveries my colleagues  and i are making revealing what we know  already and what we're not so sure about  yet  i host phenomenal once-in-a-lifetime  conversations with some of the brightest  professors authors scientists leaders  and deep thinkers alive you can ask them  questions and share your feedback with  them right here on this channel welcome  to my multiverse click here on this  playlist to see the most popular videos  on this channel and subscribe for a new  video every week